FEMA administrator chriswell said today
that she acknowledged concerns that
Florida's as it was said lacks response
to this storm so far and that whoa whoa
whoa give me a break that is nonsense
stop politicizing okay stop it we
declared a state of emergency when this
thing wasn't even formed we've had
people in here you've had counties doing
uh they've done a lot of hard work and
and honestly you're trying to attack me
I get but like you're attacking these
other people who've worked very hard and
so so that's just totally false saying
that Florida wasn't prepared you've been
here you know the facts uh what do you
make of that uh that sort of push to to
try and make this something that's not
real
well we shouldn't be surprised that the
media will use any excuse I mean they
would gladly use death and destruction
uh to take out Ron DeSantis I mean he is
Enemy Number One for sort of the
mainstream machine right now because
he's an effective politician and by the
way the most effective politician in the
world if we could have a fictitious
politician in a magical fantasy land
that person would not be able to stop
Every Act of God what I can tell you on
the ground here is even in the last
couple days when it looked like the
hurricane was going to directly hit
Miami at first you know going to Home
Depot going to the stores around here
there were lines everywhere people were
respectful and nice and helping out each
other and helping get propane in cars
and all of those things and by every
measure of everything I've seen and I
have a decent amount of Insider contacts
here in Florida the the DeSantis
Administration has done absolutely
everything possible well in advance of
all of this the cleanup is going to be
swift hopefully we get that that money
from the federal government but Florida
is going to do everything absolutely
possible but they're just going to try
to find they're going to try to find one
little slip up one little moment and
they'll go for it but that's why
desantis's answer was so perfect because
he said look I know you're trying to get
me but there are all these other good
people working here that's the right
attitude because this is it's not about
him this is about a state that needs
some help right now we're going to do a
lot of it internally but we'll need some
external as well if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell